alors maintenant on va jouer un peu à
l'arroseur arrosé
je vous faire l'interview raphaël mais
alors bonjour monsieur mais ce rallye
tout d'abord je me présente je m'appelle
tu y ailles paillasson je vous demande
d'être indulgent avec moi c'est ma
première interview
merci voilà les this way vous allez
jouer au stade de france mais contre
quelle équipe je vais jouer seul
j'aurais peut-être des premières parties
ouais est ce que je peux vous appeler
pierre palmade
parce que pour moi c'est mieux mon
patron et voulait un mec connu oui c'est
possible je vous appelle je ne sais bien
palmade c'est beaucoup d'honneur alors
j'ai prévu d'accord ah ben je suis
d'accord pourra lui demande après la
pire points alors pierre votre sketch
sur la chauve souris vous avez une fuite
vous avez une idée comment j'ai eu
l'idée monsieur moi j'aime beaucoup les
animaux ont pu en plus je suis
spécialisé dans les nac les nouveaux
animaux de compagnie et je cherchais
absolument le problème c'est quand on
achète des chauves souris quand on les
récupère dans le second on sait pas
comment les soigner
ouais c'est ça donc là j'ai trouvé un
spécialiste du nac et votre sketch sur
l'eshop chauve-souris wes kim on avait
parlé j'ai dix ans et on parlera remonte
bien et votre sketch le lâcher de
[ __ ] vous n'avez pas peur de vous
attirer les foudres des chasseurs non
les chasseurs vous savez je les emmerde
un peu quand même
mais je n'aime pas du tout c'est vrai
que sur votre maison vous avez marqué
j'encule châssis est en dessous c'est
écrit reculer c'est vulgaire mais
chasseurs c'est tellement pire alors
qu'hier alors il ya une question que
j'ai picardie semble enfin je vais
retourner un petit peu à ma manière quoi
est ce que tu sais le pouce d'une amie
s'est trompé ça dépend s'ils avaient des
petits bras à l'eau c'est ce connard de
baffie comment ça va et plus bon comment
ça va oui le chèque est pas arrivé je
sais pas moi ils m'ont dit qu'ils
avaient envoyées ouais ouais non c'est
pas le moment d'envoyer l'avocat la
pauvre pour une histoire de chèque est
pas arrivée des codes pour l'instant
bras
raphaël mezrahi je dois je suis comme
celle où ça te pose